the thing with the will thing and the
slap you said in the book there's no
blood there's no guns and I had the
moment where I was like do you and I
have such a skewed sense of reality
that's been put on such a fast track due
to our
upbringing that unless it's really crazy
we don't consider it that crazy or at
least it didn't get that crazy cuz we've
seen crazy St yes yeah I think that for
me I mean and I learned this in trauma
theapy even in understanding what trauma
is because when you've seen a level of
violence on a daily basis you know or
you've seen a certain reality that's
your Norm right so then when other
people see things and that's not their
Norm yes it's kind of like oh okay
that's exactly what I'm getting at I
mean you were around guns you were
around violence you dealt drugs none of
these things I knew about you yeah well
you Pro you know I mean that's not
something that you just yeah you know
what I mean well I you need in my case
right you needed some context you know I
needed to wait until I could actually
tell the story and give some context you
know because just talking about it you
kind of like like whoa whoa whoa hold up
hold up take me back so I feel like
that's just standard issue like I'm like
oh drugs and got AG sure why not like
but you weren't doing them you were just
dealing them whereas your mom and dad
were doing them using my my my father
was a drug addict too right that's I
think what led a lot to the you know
homelessness and yeah yeah um my father
had bouts of that as well I mean that's
sort of the bond I wasn't expecting to
have with you and your life you're such
a Survivor and I don't say that lightly
because I I can barely see that about
myself right when people are like what
you've survived I'm like what yeah what
are you talking about yeah exactly I'm
the say can you see that about yourself
now absolutely absolutely and then you
have kids and they're being brought up
in a much more protected way so are mine
how do you deal with that as a mom where
do we let them fail where do we over
lean in are we a helicopter like
generation yeah I've had to learn how to
listen because they are living a life
that I I don't know right yeah I don't
know it either right I I don't know so I
I can relate more to the upbringing of
their cousins right than them
necessarily because I didn't grow up in
a lifestyle like that so I've had to
learn think thank you drew Cheers Cheers
what do you think why did you start to
do the red table talks I was so inspired
by how much you laid it out there as
much as I have had it all out there I
was like
shoot that is like there's no holding
back and and why have you decided to
your life is so public and yet you said
no there's so many deeper layers here
yeah why do you make that conscious
choice I think it's important I think
when it it's part of the learning even
as much as people might want to
romanticize what life in Hollywood
should be um I think that it gives a
real beautiful opportunity to offer your
self in a way for learning right which
is what this book is about as
[Music]
well